what do I do when I'm bored I rank stuff
so guys apropos of nothing because we're
slightly in a little bit of a lull
between new releases of things that fall
under the Marvel Cinematic Universe
banner I'm gonna just rank everything
they've done up to this point why cuz I
feel like it I am including the TV shows
in this and I am separating the season
so I am gonna rank seasons individually
this is probably the only time I'm gonna
get to do this because some of the TV
shows I may not continue to watch
anymore and and I'm kind of hitting the
the point of diminishing returns but
regardless at this point I am caught up
on pretty much all the stuff I will
point out in any place where there's
gaps and I and I'm making leaps but as I
do this is but we'll start at the bottom
we will work our way up now before I get
started and I start with the stuff that
is at the bottom of my ranking let me
say I actually don't think that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has produced a
flat-out bad movie or TV show yet
however they have released some mediocre
stuff and that's what's gonna be at the
bottom end that's what we'll start with
so since I'm breaking up the seasons
that means there's 21 entries in this so
starting at the bottom of the barrel
number 21 Iron Man 2 just it's filler I
mean that's it is Gavin kid anybody
remember almost anything that happened
in this cuz I barely can at this point
it was just a placeholder it was just
reminding everybody that Iron Man was
around and the MCU was the thing that
was being built until they could get to
the next film there's some decent
moments in it but they don't add up to
anything there's very little overarching
plot or story it's just completely
forgettable number 20 Captain America
the First Avenger now I know this thing
has his fans and I've talked about this
before how I think that some people
really overwrite this heavily Captain
America himself brilliant love him he's
perfect the way he's portrayed the way
he's acted the CGI used to make him
skinny and just the whole way he fits
into the world is spot-on but almost
everything else
on it I take issue with Tommy Lee Jones
is sleeping and through this movie I
don't get what anybody sees in Hugo
Weaving is red skull he's just a
completely generic villain I don't like
the fact that they had to detach Hydra
from the Nazi be like they're even worse
than the Nazi just haven't be Nazis
what's wrong with that and Hydra itself
is completely ineffective they come off
like you like Cobra in the GI Joe
cartoon it never feels like they're a
threat it never feels like they're
winning they're just being beaten back
constantly and the strength of the
central performance is the only reason
this isn't at the bottom number nineteen
Thor - now a bit like Iron Man - this
just feels like filler and there's very
little you I really can remember about
it but again it does have strong moments
it does have strong scenes and like
Captain America it does have a strong
central performance from Chris Hemsworth
but also has an additional strong
performance from Tom Hiddleston as Loki
and the two of them together are what
Bowie this movie up the list ever so
slightly but again much like Iron Man -
this just felt like filler this felt
like a placeholder until they got to
something more impactful number 18
agents of shield season 1 the first
season was boring until oh I don't know
how many episodes were left maybe six or
five episodes left the point at which
the events of Captain America the Winter
Soldier crossed over and shield got
dismantled that's when the show actually
finally got interesting in his last few
episodes they're actually genuinely
really good but up until that point the
the bog-standard villain of the week
format it just it felt so nineties and
it felt like a completely outdated
method it wasn't integrating into the
MCU in a way that we had all hoped and
it wasn't doing its own thing in any way
that was exciting
again it picked up at the end of season
but man it was a slog for a while number
17 The Incredible Hulk again there's
some nice moments in this I think Edward
Norton does pretty well and I'm kind of
a sucker for Tim Roth but I really loved
Tim Blake Nelson
and I'm so annoyed that they never
brought him back to be the leader
because I think he would have been great
and obviously they set that up they
obviously took a lot of notes and
learned from sort of the criticism of
angley's Hulk that what people were
missing from that is hold smashing and
they give us that and they give us that
pretty well and but it's it's all fairly
mindless there's not there's really kind
of nothing going on under the surface
it's just you know sometimes he's a guy
on the run sometimes this is a monster
isn't this kind of fun is but it's
popcorn fun you know you eat it's gone
you don't remember much after that
number 16 agents of shield season 3 now
this was a season that that it was
strong coming in because obviously just
by process of elimination you can figure
out that season 2 was by my estimation
the best season so it was coming off
with a strong second season it started
out pretty well and had some good
individual episodes as it went along but
it just it just lost steam as it went
and the whole revelation of Hydra kind
of being a cult
I don't think added anything to it and I
really was mourning the loss of Ward as
a character because as it comes as far
as I'm concerned Hyde is not Ward these
are different characters they killed a
really great villain to give us a more
generic villain wearing his skin there
was also a real am page in the
relationship drama in the third season
and I didn't need any of that number 15
agent Carter season 1 so I know a lot of
people who really loved this right off
the bat and I thought it was fine I
thought the period setting was pretty
good I wasn't thrilled with the whole
she has to make her way in a man's world
think of a I figure this woman more than
paid her dues you know during World War
Two and I mean I get that you know
society as a whole hadn't gotten to the
point where a woman can you know is
expected to hold up the same as a man
but I mean come on they set her back so
much that's like did anybody look at her
military record but we got you know sort
of this proto version
the Black Widow program and we got some
fun with the Howling Commandos and and
it was nice it was pleasant it was fun
number 14 agent Carter season 2 why am i
right giving a ranking above the other
one well it just feels like they hit
their rhythm a little bit better now
full disclosure I did not actually get
to finish this season for whatever
reason my DVR just got weird and stopped
recording it and I didn't care enough to
finish and you think that would make me
rank it below season one but I don't
know overall it felt more comfortable it
felt it felt less like it was trying to
prove something and there's nothing
wrong with trying to prove something but
I like the more easygoing feel of the
about half a season in ourselves that I
saw worth of agent Carter season 2
number 13 Iron Man 3 now I know there
are some people who cannot stand Iron
Man 3 largely because of the twist
involving the Mandarin I actually think
it was kind of a clever twist but they
didn't execute it as well as they could
have but again it's got a lot of great
moments in it's got a lot of great ideas
in it I like the iron Legion I actually
like Tony with that kid that whole
segment I thought worked really well but
there are lots of little things that are
just if the guide Pierce's killing is
not a particularly great villain the
relationship drama with Pepper Potts I
really could have done with that I
really loved their dynamic and the first
one where you know it's not even a will
they won't Lee it's just like a they're
really good friends who drive each other
nuts so having it just be relationship
at this point I didn't love war machine
continues to be marginalized so much
that you actually wonder why they even
bother giving him the suit but there are
moments that work and there are things I
like and it you know it balances to this
kind of mid-level ranking that it gets
number 12 agents of shield season 2
already said this was the best season a
lot and it definitely was this was where
yah we had a clear identifiable villain
early on in the form of Whitehall and
war Ward became my favorite character in
this and I hated him
season 1 hated him so much but they
doubled down on revealing how bad and
just blah
get in horrible he was as a human being
I'm just sitting there going yeah
drops and it just it makes that betrayal
that I thought you know didn't work in
the first season just retro actively
become so much better because you just
revealed wow this guy really is the
worst and all the stuff that they did
would be in humans I thought it was
really intriguing it still overall
didn't really bring itself up to the
level of more than like a a decent
season of Buffy the Vampire Slayer but
you know that's still fun and it was
still enjoyable and it was by far the
most consistencies in the show has had
number eleven Avengers age of Ultron now
this one is kind of funny because if I
look at any individual scene almost any
individual scene is terrific and
actually many of them better than a lot
of them movie scenes in movies that I'm
going to rank above it but they just
don't quite add up into a cohesive whole
the way that I wanted it to and it does
you know you feel the weight of how much
was cut and you feel sort of the burden
that Joss Whedon had because the thing
had to maintain continuity at least as
much as it had to tell its own story and
you feel the weight of it is starting to
the gears are starting to grind a little
bit but like I said there's a ton of
individual season that I love a ton of
character moments that I love I like
Ultron as a villain and this is a fun
movie it just doesn't quite all fit
together really seamlessly alright we're
up into the upper half the top ten
number ten ant-man just a good time it's
a heist
it's a rollick it's light-hearted and
it's just got a wonderful vibe and I
like that Marvel is willing to switch it
up and give a more than you know
they put stakes in it they imply that
things could go really bad at this
technology gets the wrong hands but they
they're not it's not world ending stakes
it's more or less Hank comes pride more
than anything else that's at stake here
and I like the performances I thought
Michael Douglas was terrific and Paul
Rudd was good and I mean the
we're the main thing is that the villain
is weak and that unfortunately is a
recurring weakness across a lot of
Marvel movies not unique to this one but
this this is light fun but as opposed to
say the Incredible Hulk which I said was
like popcorn fun but Wrangler down this
one just it leaves more of an impact
because it feels more unique you've seen
monsters terror places before we you
haven't seen a guy shrink down to this
and run across a gum barrel and then
punch a guy in the face as he grows back
to normal size that you haven't seen
before so while this is still like it is
more memorable number 9 daredevil season
2 I like daredevil a lot and season 2
had some really good things but it felt
very truncated it felt very segmented in
terms of the Elektra stuff and the
Punisher stuff and I didn't feel like
the to internet particularly well I'm
who's saying the highlight by far are
the episode set in the jail that
involved kingpin oh man do I love
kingpin and I think I think the Punisher
stuff was handled pretty well it's not
my favorite depiction of Frank Castle
Ray Stevenson still gets that for my
part and I thought the take on Elektra
was interesting kind of fun if you're a
real big fan of Elektra from the comics
you may take more issue with it but I
was happy to see stick back and in
overall things were just nice and they
were working but it wasn't feeling as
fresh as the first season and like I
said that the different plot threads
that are going on aren't mixing quite as
well as they did in the first season so
this one gets a lower ranking number 8
for now on paper this should probably
rank a lot lower I mean a ton of it is
set on earth which is not nearly as
interesting is that Asgard I mean it's
only something they did to save money
heck the 80s Masters of the Universe
movie did the same thing but the he's
Masters of the Universe but we didn't
have Chris Hemsworth and he what a star
turn he gives in this as for he is so
great and Tom Hiddleston as loki is good
but loki the one really come into his
own as a villain until later appearances
but he's still good and this actually
everybody's really good in this and all
the actors have gotten good chemistry
and they bounce off each other really
well and it's the performances that
elevate and keep this thing from sagging
under the weight of what is kind of a
clunky budget saving set up those
limitations do keep it from going higher
but the performances and the characters
are also enough to put it in this upper
half number 7
guardians of the galaxy what a fun time
this was and it really does feel like
one of those retro attempts and give you
like the 80s attempts at being the next
Star Wars that were always on a low
budget was given a good budget this is a
good version of what all those knockoffs
could have only hoped to be it's it's
got a wild variety of characters I loved
all the main cast but like a man and
like other things that I'm going to talk
about the villain is weak Ronan the
accuser is kind of a nonentity because
you know that Thanos is going on in the
background and nebula has a lot more
charisma and just feels like a better
character anyway so he's just kind of
yeah he's there and I personally think
the the climax the ultimate conclusion
and the way they defeat the villain is
kind of cheesy it kind of took me out of
the movie a little bit but when this
thing is going in its first you know
three quarters or so it's just moving
along it's fast and it's fun and it's
funny and the characters are bouncing
off each other and they're getting on
each other's nerves jet it's the right
way but bonding just enough that it all
balances just a lot of fun number six
daredevil season 1 now I've mentioned
that some other things Marvel tends to
have a villain problem weak villains not
the case in daredevil season 1 kingpin
Vincent D'Onofrio
playing Wilson Fisk so good he owns the
screen when he's on it and the other
aspects are good too I like Charlie Cox
as Matt Murdock I like the priest
I like foggy Nelson and people complain
about foggy I don't understand why I
actually really like him and there's the
introduction of the more mystical
elements and it's and it makes you go
ooh but they don't intrude on the story
and that and that was
the reason that season two was more
ranked more lower than me is that the
mystical ninja stuff was starting to
take over and I didn't like that as much
as sort of the ground-level him him
dealing with street crime and that's
what he's and that's what daredevil does
in the first season I like that better
we're getting pretty close to getting up
there now number five iron man one the
one that started it all
not only is Robert Downey jr. phenomenal
in this part from the very beginning but
just the way the whole thing is paced
and the way his characters art goes in
the way that he grows I really like it
I love how good the film and the
performance are at just showing how
smart he is in that because this movie
more than anything is just about his own
journey of discovery of what he's what
he's been causing to happen in the world
and what he can do to make it better it
does have a little bit of the villain
problem although from my part Jeff
Bridges is energetic and charismatic
enough as an actor that he lifts it
above say the villain an ant-man
or Ronan the accuser but it is still
that it's not a particularly memory
memorable villain overall but but the
first third of this movie especially
gold Solly gold number four Jessica
Jones and honestly this thing had a shot
at taking the top spot the only thing
that holds it back is honestly I think
the season is a few episodes to buy I
think it probably should have been 10
episodes because it hits a really
natural climax towards the end and then
it has about two episodes I think it's
like eleven and twelve where it's just
it's tying up threads that I didn't care
about at that point like the boyfriend
of Jessica Jones's best friend did
battle angle I didn't care about and and
after having caught kilgrave and then he
gets away they they just they can't find
him for a while it's like no you lost
the tension or whatever but that that
sort of slight loss of steam aside whoa
another terrific villain David Tennant
is kilgrave awesome perfectly Despicable
but also just
charming it was such a great balance for
that and Jessica Jones herself as a
character really communicating the
damage that she has been through and
suffered and survived and his fight back
against and just the way that this uses
the superhero genre to deal with some
really heavy things about trauma about
recovery about lingering damage in
baggage it's just it's so well put
together using the superheroes armor and
the tropes of that as a metaphor to
process this type of story
number three Captain America Civil War
yeah that fight at the airport is a big
part of why it's as high up as it is
because I think that fight more than any
other single fight in the MCU made me go
oh my god I have never seen this I never
thought I would because a lot of people
get hyped up just going I never thought
I'd see this character on the screen
that's not enough for me they have to do
something that I never thought I would
see and that scene at the airport with
the heroes fighting each other that is
stuff I I never would have even thought
to have asked for this stuff it never
would occurred to me that I might say
this on screen it was awesome and
honestly the story even around that all
really good and actually I think the
villain here is better than a lot of
people give him credit for as far as you
know zimos motivation and I kind of like
that it's just it's just a personal
grudge and he's not some big overarching
villain and I mean that's kind of what
made Ronan the accuser so generic so I
like that he's got a personal grudge in
it and I actually think he works fairly
well but he is not a particularly
memorable villain he's not especially
charismatic and you know and in some
ways the movie kind of blows his load
with the airport scene and then what
happens after that it still has a good
emotional punch but isn't quite as
strong overall but this movie was so
much fun and had good emotional
impactful moments so obviously it made
the top three here we go number two the
Avengers now I said when I talked about
age of Ultron that one had individual
scenes that were amazing and they
quite add up this one this is a movie
word everything builds every scene
connects the flow of the whole thing is
it's just staggering how well assemble
this is this movie is the team in the
movie is Coulson gets wonderful
highlights every character gets terrific
moments loki truly comes into his own as
a villain and just owns the screen i sat
there with a huge grin on my face from
the incident the credits began until
they finished this was so much fun but
it does not quite take the number one
spot for me the best movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is Captain America
the Winter Soldier and I think that's
because as we much fun as I had in Civil
War and in the Avengers this one gave me
impactful action and it gave me those
elements of fun but I feel like this one
has the best emotional impact well not
not quite i think jessica jones did that
slightly well but i talked about the
things holding that one back so short of
jessica jones certainly in terms of the
movies i think this one has the best
emotional weight to what's going on as
captain america finds out about Bucky as
she realizes that this organ that shield
this organization he's put his trust in
is falling apart from the inside the way
that it feels like like a 70s political
thriller but that the action hits as
hard as it does that chase with Nick
Fury is so good all of caps fights are
amazing and that I mean there's pretty
much nothing I would change about this
movie except possibly the title because
of the Winter Soldier himself doesn't
feel like he's there often enough to
warrant being the title I don't know
what else you'd call it but like this
that's a nitpicky thing that's like the
only thing that I have to complain about
this had so much fun and it has wait
it's not just like popcorn fun it is
saying something it's got emotional
weight for the characters it's the top
of the heat for me so what are your
thoughts on ranking the MCU what's your
number one what's at the bottom whatever
your thought
sorry drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned